la réponse était attendue elle est
arrivée ce matin à bruxelles après la
volte face de députés britanniques sur
les accords du bric site
l'union européenne lance sa contre
offensive par conséquent ce matin la
commission a décidé d'envoyer une lettre
de mise en demeure au gouvernement
britannique
c'est la première étape d'une procédure
d'infraction manhattan va boucler la
lettre invite le gouvernement
britannique a envoyé ses observations
dans un délai d'un mois et de plus la
commission continuera à travailler dur
pour une mise en oeuvre complète et dans
les délais de l'accord de retrait nous
respectons nos engagements and we stand
by our bachmann en septembre bruxelles
avait déjà envoyé un avertissement aux
britanniques
l'union européenne avait posé un
ultimatum au royaume uni pour être
revenu sur sa parole initial un
avertissement restée lettre morte outre
manche
pire encore mercredi dernier les députés
britanniques ont validé le projet de loi
qui revient en partie sur les accords du
break site des histoires b1 et the very
much
ce projet de loi est par sa nature même
une violation de l'obligation de bonne
foi inscrite dans l'accord de retrait
de plus s'il est adopté tel quel il sera
en totale contradiction avec le
protocole irlande irlande du nord
la date limite a été franchie hier les
dispositions problématique n'ont pas été
retirés d'un par le mak provenance il
mehmood
la procédure d'infraction pourrait aller
jusqu'à la cour de justice européenne
cette décision de bruxelles est dévoilée
alors que les négociateurs des deux
parties sont depuis mardi dans la
capitale belge
ce cycle de négociations est annoncé
comme décisif pour la suite des
relations commerciales entre européens
et britanniques
l'hypothèse d'un odile devient de plus
en plus probable alors que londres et
bruxelles ont jusqu'au 31 décembre
prochain pour trouver un accord
commercial